Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. At the turn of the 6th century BC, a man called Thales of Miletus did something truly extraordinary. He argued that instead of relying on myths and legends, the best way to understand the world was through theories and hypotheses drawn from real-world experiments, something we would call science. Where Thales led, other Greeks followed. For centuries, they made spectacular advances in understanding their world, inventing geometry, astronomy,
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要每周获取独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听资格，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。公元前 6 世纪之交，米利都的泰勒斯（Thales of Miletus）做了一件真正了不起的事。他提出，与其依赖神话和传说，不如通过从现实世界的实验中得出的理论和假设来理解世界，也就是我们所说的科学。泰勒斯开创先河后，其他希腊人纷纷效仿。几个世纪以来，他们在理解世界方面取得了惊人的进步，发明了几何学、天文学、
physics and chemistry. And then came darkness. With the end of the classical age, the world fell back into ignorance and superstition. People live like dogs in the gutter. Give a medieval churchman a science kit and he'd be roasting on the bonfire before you knew it so tom holland you can't surely disagree with such a nuanced account of the history of science can you dominic i feel like walking off this podcast right now that is i've never heard such nonsense you know the best thing about it is that yesterday you sent me an introduction that you'd written yourself for me to use quoting from one of your own essays and i just refused to use it it's from dominion yeah it's a fantastic passage
物理学和化学。接着，黑暗降临了。随着古典时代的结束，世界重新陷入无知和迷信之中。人们像阴沟里的狗一样活着。给一个中世纪的教士一套科学工具，转眼间他就会被绑在火刑柱上烧死。所以，汤姆·霍兰，你肯定不会不同意这种对科学史如此 nuanced（细腻/有深度）的描述吧，对吧，多米尼克？我感觉现在就想走出这个播客间。我从未听过如此无稽之谈。你知道最棒的是什么吗？昨天你给我发了一段你自己写的引言，让我用在节目里，还引用了你自己的某篇论文，而我拒绝使用了。那是出自《统治》（Dominion）这本书，对吧？那是一段精彩的文字。
and i just refused to use it on principle i know you did just against the spirit of the podcast oh what promote promoting our books is against the spirit of the podcast promoting your books is against my spirit of my podcast so already you've so i thought that i you know i thought that that opening thing was the most ludicrous thing you could possibly have said. Right. Well, obviously, I was setting it. Yes, I know. I know.
而我出于原则就拒绝使用它。我知道你确实这么做了，这违背了播客的精神。哦，把我们的书拿来宣传，这违背了播客的精神吗？宣传你的书违背了我这个播客的精神。所以你刚才……所以我当时想，你知道的，我觉得开场白那段话简直是你可能说出的最荒谬的话。好吧，很显然，我当时就是在营造这种气氛。是的，我知道。我知道。
So, OK, so today's topic is, we're titling it Medieval Science. And we need a top historian. We always need a top historian. Medieval science. And you, in your your introduction were kind of casting the middle ages as a dark age obscurantism yes obscurantism um we need someone who's written a book called the light ages we do about how the middle ages was far from being a period of of ignorance and superstition was um kind of opened up all kinds of astonishing ways of seeing the world that that we uh still um
好吧，所以今天的标题是，我们将其定为“中世纪科学”。我们需要一位顶尖的历史学家。我们总是需要一位顶尖的历史学家。中世纪科学。而你，在你的引言中，似乎把中世纪描绘成一个黑暗时代， obscurantism（蒙昧主义），是的，蒙昧主义。我们需要一位写过一本名为《光明时代》（The Light Ages）的书的作者。我们确实需要，这本书讲述了中世纪远非一个无知和迷信的时期，它其实……开启了各种令人惊叹的看世界的方式，而这些方式我们今天依然……
benefit from today and that person is Seb Falk author of The Light Ages joining us from Cambridge Seb are you? That's right yeah hi Seb thanks for joining us. So thanks so much for coming on the on the show and as I said we're talking about medieval science. And as you kind of tease out in your fabulous book, which I strongly recommend to anyone who's interested in this subject, even if you're not, you'll find it incredibly interesting. You kind of say that both the words medieval and science are kind of tricky, that they imply slight degrees of anachronism. Could we just look at the word medieval first? Because it does still have a kind of slightly pejorative sense, doesn't it?
从中受益，这个人就是《光明时代》的作者塞布·福尔克（Seb Falk），他从剑桥连线我们。塞布，你在吗？没错，对，嗨，塞布，谢谢你加入我们。非常感谢你来到我们的节目，正如我所说，我们今天探讨的是中世纪科学。正如你在你那本极好的书中所揭示的那样——强烈推荐给对这个主题感兴趣的任何人，即使你没兴趣，你也会觉得它妙趣横生——你提到“中世纪”和“科学”这两个词其实都有点棘手，它们都带有一点时代错乱的意味。我们能先来看看“中世纪”这个词吗？因为它确实仍然带有一种略微贬义的色彩，对吧？
Yeah. Medieval today is often used as a kind of synonym for backward or barbaric you know we talk about those medieval taliban or um you know medieval lack of wi-fi in my favorite cafe um and and things that we do like if they happen to happen uh between let's say the year 1000 and the year 1500 we call them something else we call them renaissance or or whatever it might be. But historically, the word medieval is already a bit of a way of dismissing the period, right? Because it means the bit in the middle, the bit that's less interesting. And that comes from the Renaissance when they were trying to cast themselves as the heirs to ancient Greece and Rome. And they said that everything that had happened since the fall of Rome had been just an uninteresting bit in the middle. So that history of medieval as being uninteresting
是的。“中世纪”今天经常被用作落后或野蛮的同义词。你知道的，我们会说“那些中世纪的塔利班”，或者……你知道的，我最喜欢的咖啡馆里“缺乏中世纪的 Wi-Fi”之类的话。而且我们所做的事情，如果它们恰好发生在——比方说公元 1000 年到公元 1500 年之间——我们会给它们起别的名字，我们会称之为文艺复兴，或者诸如此类的称呼。但从历史的角度来看，“中世纪”这个词本身就已经是一种贬低这个时期的方式了，对吧？因为它的意思是中间的那段，也就是不那么有趣的那段。这源于文艺复兴时期，当时的人们试图把自己塑造成古希腊和古罗马的继承人，他们声称罗马陷落以来发生的一切都只是中间一段无趣的插曲。所以，中世纪是不有趣的、
and not worthy of consideration goes way back. But I'm trying to rehabilitate it. As you do brilliantly. And that sense of the Middle Ages as something backward obviously continues into the present. So we have a question from Tim O'Neill on whose podcast I know you have appeared. Indeed, I think you've appeared on almost every podcast. And Tim, who runs a website called, what is it, History for Atheists. And his kind of
不值得考虑的历史观念，由来已久。但我正试图为它正名。正如你非常出色地做的那样。中世纪作为落后事物的这种观念，显然一直延续到了今天。因此，我们有一个来自蒂姆·奥尼尔（Tim O'Neill）的问题，我知道你曾上过他的播客。确实如此，我想你几乎上过所有的播客。蒂姆运营着一个名为——叫什么来着？——“无神论者历史”（History for Atheists）的网站。他的某种……
perspective is that atheists are as likely to believe nonsensical things about history as Christians or Muslims or whoever. And Tim asks, why is a period which gave us the optics that led to eyeglasses, the mechanics of complex astronomical clocks, logarithmic expression, the mean speed theorem and successful experiments in man flight depicted as a science-free dark age? And is it all the fault of people in the Renaissance saying that everything should be owed to the Renaissance? Or does it go deeper than that? Slightly. It's also the fault of Protestants after the Reformation and sort of into the Enlightenment
观点是，无神论者和基督徒、穆斯林或其他什么人一样，同样容易相信关于历史的荒谬事情。蒂姆提问：为什么一个孕育了通往眼镜的光学、复杂天文钟的机械学、对数表达式、平均速度定理以及人类飞行成功实验的时期，会被描绘成一个没有科学的黑暗时代？这全都要怪文艺复兴时期的人们，把一切功劳都归功于文艺复兴吗？还是说这背后的原因更深远？稍微有一点。这也要怪宗教改革后的新教徒，以及某种程度上延续到启蒙运动时期的人们……
casting Catholics as superstitious and backward and witch-burning. Actually, a lot of the stereotypes that are associated with the Middle Ages, like the burning of witches, are really more properly associated with the early modern period, or at least the beginning of the early modern period.
他们把天主教徒刻画成迷信、落后和烧死女巫的人。事实上，许多与中世纪相关的刻板印象，比如烧死女巫，其实更确切地说是与早期现代有关，或者至少是与早期现代的开端有关。
So, yeah, there's a bit of a bit of kind of edward gibbon talking about how uh people uh in in the dark ages uh were just following superstition and some of that is a way of beating up the catholics essentially and so if we then also look at the word science so i mean science in the sense that we use it today, that's quite late, isn't it? I mean, basically, it's kind of the word scientist we only get in the 19th century, mid 19th century in Oxford. The word science is kind of being used to describe the works of Aristotle or Greek philosophy or a whole range of things. So the idea of science that we have now, I mean, where does that come from? And to what extent does our use of it kind of get in the way of our understanding what people in the Middle Ages are doing?
所以，是的，这其中有点像爱德华·吉本（Edward Gibbon）的言论，说什么黑暗时代的人们……只是在盲目迷信，其中有些言论本质上只是为了抨击天主教徒。那么，如果我们再来看看“科学”这个词——我的意思是，我们今天所用的“科学”这个概念，出现得很晚，不是吗？我的意思是，基本上，“科学家”（scientist）这个词直到 19 世纪、19 世纪中叶才在牛津出现。“科学”这个词在当时被用来描述亚里士多德的著作、希腊哲学或广泛的事物。所以我们现在所理解的科学概念，到底是从哪里来的呢？我们在多大程度上因为使用了这个词，反而阻碍了我们理解中世纪的人们在做些什么？
Yeah, that's absolutely part of the problem, that the idea of a kind of modern science that's practiced by professionals in purpose-designed spaces with very specific and expensive equipment is a modern concept. But that doesn't mean that people weren't kind of looking around themselves and wondering about the universe, but they might have been doing it in different ways and for different reasons. And I think part of the problem is that we assume that there's only one way of doing science, there's only one reason to do science. But even if you actually look at modern science today, there are different motivations. Are you trying to understand the universe in a disinterested way, purely for the pleasure of finding things out, or are you trying to improve people's lives? And those are two potentially conflicting motivations
是的，这绝对是问题的一部分。那种由专业人士在专门设计的场所、使用非常具体且昂贵的设备所从事的“现代科学”的概念，是一个现代概念。但这并不意味着当时的人们没有环顾四周并对宇宙产生好奇，只是他们可能用不同的方式、出于不同的原因在做这件事。我认为问题的一部分在于，我们假设做科学只有一种方式，做科学也只有一种理由。但即使你看看今天的现代科学，其实也有不同的动机。你是想以一种超然的方式去理解宇宙，纯粹为了发现事物的乐趣，还是想改善人们的生活？这是两个可能存在冲突的动机……
for doing science. And in the Middle Ages, a lot of the motivations for doing science or for trying to understand the universe are for things that turn out to be somewhat misguided, perhaps, or that many people today would say are wrong. Trying to understand God's universe from the point of view of religious people, many atheists today would say is completely pointless. Or trying to understand the motions of the planets in order to be able to provide an astrological cure for somebody's disease, again, would be thought to be slightly misguided. But that doesn't mean that underneath those misguided motivations or overlaying those false premises isn't some really interesting
为了进行科学研究。而在中世纪，许多进行科学研究或试图理解宇宙的动机，都是为了某些事后看来可能有些误入歧途的事情，或者许多现代人会认为那是错误的事情。从宗教人士的角度来理解上帝的宇宙，许多今天的无神论者会认为这完全是毫无意义的。或者为了给某人的疾病提供占星术治疗而试图了解行星的运动，同样也会被认为有点误入歧途。但这并不意味着在这些误入歧途的动机之下，或者在这些虚假前提的覆盖之下，就没有一些非常有趣的……
methodology, some really interesting science, and some really fantastic ideas and measurements and instruments. So let's go back to the beginning of the period. So somebody asked a question online, Humphrey Clarke, he asked a question about Dan Jones's new history of the Middle Ages, in which Dan Jones talks about the late Roman Empire and its Byzantine successor kind of blocking knowledge by sort of shutting off classical learning. Do you think that's true? Is there a period at the end of the Roman Empire, in the beginning of what we'd call the Middle Ages, when people almost deliberately turn their backs on what we would now call the scientific learning of the classical era? Or does that learning
方法论、非常有趣的科学，以及一些非常棒的想法、测量方法和仪器。让我们回到这个时期的开始。有人在网上提问，汉弗莱·克拉克（Humphrey Clarke），他提出了一个关于丹·琼斯（Dan Jones）关于中世纪的新历史的问题。丹·琼斯在书中谈到晚期罗马帝国及其拜占庭继承者通过封锁古典学问来阻碍知识的传播。你认为这是真的吗？在罗马帝国末期、在我们所称的中世纪开始的时候，是否存在这样一个时期，人们几乎是故意背弃我们现在所称的古典时代的科学知识？还是说这些学问……
sort of continue unbroken as it were i mean there are cases of um church fathers saying you know you don't need to worry about this stuff there's a very famous quotation which is i think often misinterpreted by tertullian saying you know what does athens have to do with jerusalem in other words um and i'm sure tom would would weigh in on this um don't don't worry i'm itching i'm'm itching too, but I'm going to restrain myself. But I think there's equally church fathers like St. Augustine who says, you know,
某种程度上一直延续不断呢？我的意思是，确实有一些教会之父说，你知道的，你不需要担心这些东西。有一个非常著名的引言，我想经常被特土良（Tertullian）误解，他说，你知道的，“雅典与耶路撒冷有什么关系？”换句话说……而且我确信汤姆会对此发表高见……别担心，我手痒难耐，但我会克制自己的。但我认为，同样也有像圣奥古斯丁这样的教会之父，他们说，你知道的……
knowledge, pagan knowledge is like the Egyptian gold that the Israelites stole out of Egypt, except it wasn't stealing because they were putting it to better use. And so pagan knowledge in the same way could be put to better use by Christians. So, you know, there's always arguments and differences of opinion uh if there was um a period of kind of intellectual
异教知识就像埃及金字塔里的黄金，以色列人从埃及偷来的，只不过这不算偷，因为他们把它用在了更好的地方。同样的，异教知识也可以被基督徒更好地利用。所以，你知道的，如果曾经有过一个智识上的……
stagnation um it was i would say more structural it was about economic decline that uh falls the kind of uh that follows the um decline of the roman Empire. And therefore, networks of communication, systems of knowledge production were all destroyed and decaying. And so it was harder for information to be shared. But let's not forget that the Roman Empire continues in Byzantium, and knowledge continues to be spread and communicated. And then, of course, translated from Greek into Syriac and from Syriac into Arabic. And the centres of knowledge are perhaps passed to the Islamic world. So I don't think there's ever really a period when you can say that people were uninterested in knowing stuff about the world.
停滞期，总是会有各种争论和不同的意见。我要说，这更多是结构性的，是关于罗马帝国衰落之后随之而来的经济衰退。因此，交流网络、知识生产系统都被摧毁并走向衰败。这使得信息共享变得更加困难。但我们不要忘记，罗马帝国在拜占庭得以延续，知识继续传播和交流。然后，当然，从希腊语翻译成叙利亚语，再从叙利亚语翻译成阿拉伯语。知识的中心也许转移到了伊斯兰世界。因此，我认为从来没有这样一个时期，你可以真正地说人们对了解关于世界的事物不感兴趣。
People's motivations change and people's ability to protect and preserve and communicate and build on ancient knowledge had its peaks and troughs. But I think to cast the whole period as a period in which people just didn't want to know anything is a modern stereotype, basically based on kind of our own prejudices about the past, because they don't look like us and they don't think like us. And Seb, isn't it also, I mean, just to go back to this thing about how science is a recent coinage, really. And basically what science comes to mean in the 19th century is something that's not religion. And likewise, religion comes to mean something that's not science.
人们的动机在改变，人们保护、保存、传播和建立在古代知识之上的能力也有高潮和低谷。但我认为，把整个时期描绘成一个人们只是不想了解任何事情的时期，是一种现代的刻板印象，基本上是基于我们对过去的偏见，因为他们看起来不像我们，想得也不像我们。塞布，难道不是吗？我的意思是，回到关于“科学”是一个新造词的事实。基本上，科学在 19 世纪获得的含义是“非宗教”的东西。同样，宗教也变成了“非科学”的东西。
And the two are kind of separated out. But before that, it was always accepted that the attempt to understand the universe and to fathom its workings and to explain it in ways that perhaps today we would cast as science, I mean, that was always interfused with theology or with metaphysics. So Greek philosophers, I mean, you know, they believed by our lights, all kinds of mad things. And so the idea that there was, you know, that the ancient Greeks did science, and then Christians came in and stopped it because they did religion. I mean, it's a very, very seductive idea. And it's one that, you know, Kalsargen famously kind of basically promoted. But it is, I mean, that is itself a myth. Everybody right the way up to the 19th century are assuming that the world is expressive of metaphysical or indeed theological truths. I mean, wouldn't you think? Yeah, broadly speaking, I think people often assume that the world is expressive of metaphysical or indeed theological truths? I mean, wouldn't you think?
这两者被某种程度上分开了。但在那之前，人们一直公认，试图理解宇宙、探究其运作规律，并用我们今天可能视作科学的方式去解释它——我的意思是，这总是与神学或形而上学交织在一起的。所以希腊哲学家，我的意思是，按我们的标准来看，他们相信各种疯狂的事情。因此，“古希腊人做了科学，然后基督徒介入并阻止了它，因为基督徒搞的是宗教”这种观点——我的意思是，这是一个非常非常有诱惑力的想法。这也是卡尔·萨根（Carl Sagan）等人曾经大力宣传的。但它实际上……那本身就是一个神话。直到 19 世纪，每个人都认为世界表达了形而上学甚至是神学的真理。我的意思是，难道你不这么认为吗？是的，大体上说，我认为人们经常假设古希腊人是无神论者，这显然是无稽之谈。你知道的，幕后其实有很多事情在发生。但是，不，我同意你的看法，我认为问题在于我们假设人们对自然提出的问题一成不变，但事实并非如此。那些想要了解世界的人可以将他们的宗教信仰与对自然的观察融合在一起，试图解释事物是如何运作的。让我接着这个话题问，塞布。我们有一个来自欧文·威廉姆斯（Owen Williams）关于教会的问题，他说，
Yeah, broadly speaking, I think people often assume that the ancient Greeks were atheists, which is clearly nonsense. You know, there's a huge amount kind of going on behind the scenes there. But no, I agree with you that I think the trouble is that we assume that the kinds of questions that people are asking about nature have remained unchanged, and that's simply not the case. And that people who wanted to understand the world could blend their religious beliefs with their observations of nature in trying to explain how things worked. Let me pick up on that question, Seb. So we had a question from Owen Williams about the church, and he says,
中古教会对科学研究的支持程度如何？我的意思是，我想你可能会说——我预料到你的回答会是——中古教会可能没有一个一刀切的立场，而且科学研究独立于教士们所做之事的这种观念，是一个现代的、具有时代错乱色彩的概念，是这样吗？是的，所以正如汤姆已经说过的，科学可以意味着一大堆事情，因为拉丁语中的“scientia”意思是知识，任何知识体系都可以是一门科学。所以天文学可以是一门科学。音乐可以是一门科学。神学可以是一门科学。因此，甚至连“教会反科学”这种说法本身也是毫无意义的。
to what extent was the medieval church in favor of scientific research i mean i guess what you might say i'm anticipating your answer is that the medieval church maybe doesn't have a blanket position but also there's no the idea of scientific research being separate from things that churchmen do is a modern is a kind of anachronism is that right yeah so the the the sciences as tom already said already said, can mean a whole bunch of things because the word scientia in Latin means knowledge and any kind of system of knowledge can be a science. So astronomy can be a science. Music can be a science. Theology can be a science. And so even the statement that the church is anti-science doesn't really make any sense.
你知道的，教会怎么可能反知识呢？当然，知识有不同的形式，机构也经常试图维护它们的权力。因此，如果教会……甚至把教会视为一个单一的整体也是有问题的，因为教会当然有不同的网络，在不同的地方有不同的能力来控制人们的行为。是的，好吧，塞布，你谈到教会内部有不同的机构。所以其中之一显然是修道院制度。在你的书《光明时代》中，你重点关注了圣奥尔本斯的伟大本笃会修道院。你重点关注了那里的一位特定僧侣——给我们讲讲他吧，因为他是一个有些神秘的人物，而你基本上赋予了他血肉。给我们讲讲他的生活以及他能做的事情，因为我认为这能让听众对我们谈论中世纪科学时到底在谈论什么有一个直观的感受。
You know, how can the church be anti-knowledge there's different forms of knowledge uh of course institutions often try and preserve their power so if um the if if the church and even talking about the church as a kind of monolithic body is problematic because of course the church has uh different networks and different uh abilities to to control um people's behavior in different places. Yeah, well, Seb, you've talked about how there are different institutions in the church. And so obviously one of them is the institution of monasticism. And in your book, The Light Ages, you focus on the great Benedictine monastery at St Albans. And you focus on one particular monk there who will tell us about him because because he's he's a kind of shadowy figure who essentially you kind of almost give form to. But tell us something about his life and what he is able to do, because I think that would give listeners a sense of of exactly what we're talking about when we talk about medieval science.
好的。这个人名叫韦斯特维克的约翰（John of Westwick）或者约翰·韦斯特维克。韦斯特维克是圣奥尔本斯以西的一个小村庄，他大约出生于 1350 年代，但我们无法完全确定。关于他的关键点不在于他在科学史上有多么举足轻重。事实上，我选择他的原因是为了摆脱这样一种观念：科学是由伟人们凭空捏造出想法并恩赐给感恩的公众而产生的。科学是无数人的工作，其中许多人我们从未听说过，也永远不会听到，这是通过他们的实践完成的。所以我想展示的是，约翰·韦斯特维克在做科学时到底在做什么，他是如何……
Yeah. So this man's name is John of Westwick or John Westwick. Westwick was a little hamlet just to the west of St Albans, and he was born probably sometime in the 1350s, but we can't be entirely sure. And the point about him is not that he's massively important in the history of science. In fact, the reason I chose him was to get away from this idea that science is produced by great men plucking ideas out of thin air and bestowing them on a grateful public. Science is the work of countless people, many of whom we've never heard of and will never hear of, and it is done through their practices. So what I wanted to show was what was it that John Westwick was doing when he was doing science and how is he
代表了中世纪做科学和思考自然的方式的。从很多方面来说，他是一个普通的僧侣，但在某些方面又不同寻常、非同寻常，特别是因为他从未在一座修道院里度过整个职业生涯，他四处游历了很多地方。他从富裕的圣奥尔本斯修道院来到了他们位于北海悬崖上的泰恩茅斯（Tynemouth）分支修道院。那里有时是圣奥尔本斯的僧侣们的流放地或前哨站。他们被派往那里，要么是为了在这个荒凉的环境中证明自己，要么可能是因为他们在圣奥尔本斯惹了麻烦而受到惩罚——而他们确实经常惹麻烦……所以丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson）可不想听到这个。不，不，乔纳森·威尔逊（Jonathan Wilson）也不会。
kind of representative of the medieval way of doing science and thinking about nature. And so he's in many ways an ordinary monk but in some ways unusual and extraordinary particularly in the fact that he'd never, he didn't stay in one monastery for his whole career, he travelled around quite a lot, he went from the wealthy monastery of St Albans up to their daughter house at Tynemouth on the cliffs overlooking the North Sea, which was sometimes an exile or an outpost for monks from St Albans. They were sent there either to prove themselves in this inhospitable environment or perhaps as punishment if they got into trouble in St Albans, which they did quite a lot so dan jackson wouldn't like to hear that no no he would jonathan wilson they
他们不会……可以被流放到东北部这种想法？是的，好吧，我们有一些来自泰恩茅斯的僧侣写给圣奥尔本斯的引人入胜的信件，上面写着：“别上这儿来，天气太糟糕了，你只能看到北海的泡沫和尖叫的海鸥，这里能吃的只有鱼，简直糟透了。”任何去过英格兰东北部的人都可以证明，这些全都是真的。好吧，关于约翰·韦斯特维克，我们可以确定的一点是——因为我们不确定他是作为一种考验——作为一个有前途的年轻僧侣——还是作为一种惩罚被派往那里的——但他并没有呆太久。这也是我认为这可能是一种惩罚的原因之一，因为他显然急于离开，而他离开的方式是去参加十字军东征。
wouldn't the idea that you can exile to the northeast yeah well we have some fascinating letters back from monks at time earth back to st albans saying don't come up here the weather is awful you just get foam from the north sea and these shrieking gulls and all there is to eat is fish and it's just awful and anyone who's been to the northeast can attest that this is all completely true well one thing we can say about john westwick because we don't know for sure whether he was sent there as uh as kind of a test uh as a promising young monk or as a punishment but he didn't stay very long uh which is one reason why I think it might have been a punishment, because he was clearly keen to leave and he left by going on crusade.
他加入了 1383 年的“主教十字军东征”（Bishop's Crusade），该十字军没有去圣地，而是去了佛兰德斯。这是百年战争中的一段插曲，当时诺维奇主教说：“我们这里遇到了贸易禁令的问题，英国的羊毛贸易完全被搞砸了。”所以这有点像脱欧。对。有点像脱欧十字军东征。对。或者像《幽灵的威胁》。那是关于贸易禁令的。但这是一次成功的……有点像弗罗斯特勋爵（Lord Frost）会做的事。好吧，弗罗斯特勋爵会怎么做？弗罗斯特勋爵会去围攻一个友好的城市吗？这就是问题所在。
He joined up the 1383 Bishop's Crusade, which didn't go to the Holy Land, but to Flanders. It was kind of an episode in the Hundred Years' War where the Bishop of Norwich said, we've got a problem with a trade embargo here and the English wool trade is just completely messed up. So it's kind of Brexit. Yeah. Kind of Brexit crusade. Yeah. Or the Phantom Menace. That's with a trade embargo here and the English wool trade is just completely messed up. So it's kind of Brexit. Yeah.
几乎可以肯定。他做得出来，是的。因为他们在 1383 年就是这么做的。他们围攻了伊普尔（Ypres）城，结果所有人都得了痢疾，军队不得不耻辱地撤退，放弃了他们已经取得的战果。领导这次十字军东征的诺维奇主教在议会遭到弹劾。
Kind of Brexit crusade. Or the phantom menace. That's about a trade embargo. But it was about a successful... It's kind of Lord Frost would do it. Well, what would Lord Frost do? Would Lord Frost besiege a friendly city? That's the question.
所以约翰·韦斯特维克参与了这件事。后来，当他在 1390 年代初出现在伦敦时，他正在为这种非常复杂的天文仪器绘制图纸，这种仪器被称为“等分仪”（equatorium），这是一种用于计算行星位置的装置，用于天文学和占星术。所以他有很多兴趣。他把大部分时间——像僧侣们过去和现在所做的那样——花在抄袭、编辑、作注、评论和翻译上。这些都是中世纪的基本学术活动。
Almost certainly. Past him, yeah. Because that's what they did in 1383. They besieged the city of Ypres and they all got dysentery and the army had to retreat in ignominy, giving up the gains they had made. And the Bishop of Norwich who led the crusade was impeached before parliament.
我们今天认为这些活动有点枯燥，缺乏创造力。但中世纪是一个知识通过在前人和前辈的成就上积累而获得的时期。也就是站在巨人的肩膀上，正如牛顿所说。站在巨人的肩膀上，正如牛顿所说。但牛顿所引用的，当然是这方面的一句中世纪谚语。牛顿本人当然说过，自然哲学的目的是探讨上帝。所以我们也不应该把他作为某种无神论科学的旗手。那么约翰·韦斯特维克到底在做什么？我的意思是，他兴趣的焦点是什么？这种……嗯，你提到过，你几乎说它是一台计算机。
So John Westwick was on this. And then when he turns up a little bit later in the early 1390s in London, where he was drawing up plans for this very complex astronomical instrument called an equatorium which is a sort of device for computing the positions of the planets so it's for astronomy and astrology and so he's got a bunch of interests he spends a lot of his time as monks do and as monks did copying and editing and glossing and commenting and translating. And these are the kind of basic scholarly activities of the Middle Ages,
是的。从非常字面的意义上说，计算机从某个来源获取你输入的信息，以某种方式进行处理，然后吐出新的信息。我的意思是，这字面意思上就是计算机的作用。这个装置采用了行星运动的基本参数和组成部分，你把它们输入进去，转动小表盘，拉动一些细绳，然后你就可以在这个黄铜和木质圆盘的边缘上读出经度和天球经度。
which today we think are a little bit arid and a little bit lacking in creativity. But the period of the Middle Ages was very much one in which knowledge was gained by building on the achievements of your forebears and your predecessors. So standing on the shoulders of giants, as Newton says. Standing on the shoulders of giants, as Newton says. But Newton was quoting, of course, a medieval proverb in that respect. Newton himself, of course, said that the purpose of natural philosophy was to discourse of God. So we shouldn't make him the standard bearer for
行星沿黄道的经度，黄道就是太阳在全年背景星空中运行的黄道带。所以你可以找到行星的位置，通过这样做，你就可以画出星座运势。再次强调，占星术在我们看来似乎相当迷信和无稽之谈，但在中世纪，这是一门非常严肃的科学，它基于这样一个原理：既然太阳加热地球、创造四季，月亮牵引潮汐，那么为什么其他行星就不能对地球上的事物产生影响呢？人类作为宏观世界的微观缩影，人类作为宇宙的迷你版，包含了宇宙所包含的元素，反映了宇宙的构成。所以我们……
some atheistic science either. So what exactly is it that John Westwick is doing? I mean, what is the focus of his interest? This kind of, well, you talked, I mean, you kind of said it was computer almost. Yeah. I mean, a computer in the very literal sense that a computer takes information that you put into it from some source, it processes it in some way and it spits out new information. I mean, that's literally, I suppose, what a computer does. And this one takes the basic parameters and components of the motions of the planets and you put them in and you turn a little dial and you pull some strings and then you read on the rim of this brass and wooden disc the positions in longitude and celestial longitude
在某种意义上，总是在反映我们周围的事物。如果你了解天空中发生了什么，天气也是可以预测的。因此，占星术的知识是深奥而重要的，但天文学确实是第一门数学科学，第一门真正精确的科学。所以对我们来说，它看起来确实很科学，因为他们在设计仪器，比如星盘，来寻找事物的位置并进行非常精确的测量。我可以接着谈谈这个装置，这台机器吗？这种机器有多普遍？——我的意思是，我们不认为人们会——因为我们当中有太多人沦为了刻板印象的奴隶，我想。我们不认为中世纪的僧侣会发明机器或使用机器，但这有多普遍？
of the planets along the ecliptic, which is the zodiac where the sun travels against the background of stars throughout the year. So you can find the positions of the planets, and by doing so you can draw up a horoscope. And again, astrology seems to us to be quite superstitious and nonsense, but in the Middle Ages it was a very serious science, and it was based on the principle that if the sun heats up the earth, you know, creates the seasons and the moon pulls the tides, then why shouldn't the other planets also affect things down here on earth? And humans as a microcosm of the macrocosm, humans as a sort of mini version of the universe, containing elements as the universe contains elements, reflect the makeup of the universe. So we're
我的意思是，人们……这是一个充满发明和摆弄各种小玩意儿的时代吗？还是说这在后来的早期现代时期才更普遍地出现？“摆弄”（tinkering）绝对是这个词。这是一个充满创新、改进、渐进式改进的时代。他们对各种装置非常热衷。他们对小玩意儿很感兴趣。
always in some sense reflecting what's around us. And the weather as well is predictable if you understand what's happening up there in the heavens. So knowledge of astrology was profound and important, but also astronomy was really the first mathematical science, the first truly precise science. So to us, it really does look quite scientific, because they're devising instruments, instruments like astrolabes, to find the positions of things and to measure very precisely. So can I pick up on the device, the machine, as it were? How common, I mean, we don't think of people, because we, so many of us are kind of slaves to the stereotype, I suppose. We don't think of monks in the Middle Ages inventing machines or working with machines, but how common was this?
这就是我们看到第一批机械钟的时期，你知道的，最初是相当基础的机械钟，后来是更复杂的机械钟。这也是在修道院里发生的，因为计时对修道院的一天至关重要。你需要知道什么时候去做礼拜。所以你在书中说，机械钟无疑是中世纪最重要的发明。
I mean, did people, was this an age of invention and of kind of tinkering with contraptions and things? Or does that come later in the early modern period more generally? Tinkering is definitely the word. It's an age of kind of innovation, of improvement, of incremental improvement. And they were really very keen on devices. They were keen on gadgets.
然后令人震惊的是，你竟然忽略了索尔兹伯里大教堂的钟。好吧，我觉得……萨勒姆手稿的制作者们已经在宣传那个方面做得很出色了，但还有其他非常重要的中世纪钟表。问题实际上在于中世纪的钟表大多没有保存下来，因为中世纪的人非常擅长循环利用。但基本上，没有计时，没有精确的计时，我们就没有 GPS。我们也没有……你知道的，我们今天都沦为奴隶的那种在线送货时段以及所有这些东西。所以，你知道的，如果没有中世纪的创新，我们甚至无法安排这个播客的日程。所以，你知道的，我想你在中世纪看到的不是原子钟、卫星等等带来的那种精确计时。但你确实看到的是这种对细节的关注和对精度的关注。中世纪的人痴迷于将事物计算到完全无法观察的细节水平。你知道的，你会看到他们将行星的位置计算到……你知道的，十亿分之一度，而他们在天空中根本不可能观察到这一点。但计算的过程、计算的方法是……
And this is the period when we see the first mechanical clocks, you know, first quite basic mechanical clocks and then later more complex mechanical clocks. And that's happening in the monasteries as well because timekeeping was essential to the monastic day. You needed to know when to press. So you say in your book, the mechanical clock was surely the most significant invention of the middle ages
他们以极其煞费苦心的方式做的事情。但就钟表而言，这是由僧侣专门开发的吗，因为他们需要它来记录他们礼拜或其他活动的时间？这其中有一个动机吗？这是一个好问题。这也是历史学家们一直在争论的问题。所以确实有这种实际的动机。但如果你看看他们制造的钟表，就会发现它们的制造远远超出了那个功能需求。因此，也有这样一种感觉：当他们制造钟表时，他们是在重现宇宙。他们这样做是为了……某种程度上理解造物主的思想。我们有后来更为人所知的“发条宇宙”的隐喻。但即使在当时，
and then shockingly you neglect to mention the clock in salisbury cathedral well i feel like um the sege script alpoisoners have already done an excellent job on publicizing that one um but there are other really important medieval clocks the trouble is actually with medieval clocks is that most of them don't survive because medieval people were really good at recycling. But basically, without timekeeping, without precise timekeeping, we don't have GPS. We don't have, you know, the kind of online delivery slots
在中世纪最受欢迎的科学教科书中，约翰·德·萨科博斯科（John of Sacrobosco）的《天球论》（Sphere）开篇就描述了“世界的机器”。所以此时的世界已经被视为一台机器。如果世界是一台机器，为了……他们说，如果你能通过观察一个工匠制造的机器来理解这个工匠的思想，那么你就能理解上帝的思想……
that we're all slaves to these days and all the rest of it. So, you know, we couldn't have scheduled this podcast without the innovations of the Middle Ages. So, you know, I suppose what you see in the Middle Ages is not the kind of precise timekeeping that atomic clocks and satellites and all the rest of it. But what you do see is this attention to detail and this attention to precision. People in the Middle Ages were obsessed with calculating things to levels of detail that were completely unobservable. You know, you get them computing the positions of the planets to, you know, billionths of degrees, which they could never have observed in the sky. But the process of computation, of calculation, was something that
通过观察造物，如果你能在盒子里重现宇宙，那么你在某种程度上就可以理解它的组成部分，从而理解上帝。所以这背后有一种神学的动机，当然，这……当然，这也是一种展示你的权力和控制力的方式。正因如此，钟表在 13 世纪末被发明后不久，到了 15 世纪，我们就在市政厅和市民建筑、非宗教建筑中看到了钟表，它们成为了地方当局展示权力、展示控制力的一种方式。你知道的，你在斯特拉斯堡或伯格的市政厅装上一个钟……
they did in an extremely painstaking way. But just on clocks, is this developed by monks specifically because they need it to keep track of the hours for their services or whatever? Is that one of the motivations? That's a great question. And it's one that historians keep arguing about. So there is this practical motivation. But if you look at the clocks that they make, they make them well beyond that capability. And so there is also a sense that when they're making a clock, they are reproducing the cosmos. And they are doing so in order to kind of understand the mind of the creator. We have that sort of metaphor of the clockwork universe that becomes better known later. But even at the time,
钟表是在哪里发明的？是诺维奇吗？正如我所说，我们没有现存最早的钟表，因为它们都被熔化、回收、销毁或更换了。但我们有 1270 年代和 80 年代在英格兰许多大教堂和修道院里关于钟表的早期记录，但它们可能也存在于欧洲的其他地方。这很棘手，因为当然，当时有水钟、日晷……当然有水钟、日晷，还有其他形式的计时技术。由于我们只有文字记录……当他们说“钟”时，我们并不确切知道它是机械钟、水钟还是别的什么东西……而且记录……
in the most popular medieval scientific textbook, the Sphere of John of Sacrobosco starts off by describing the machine of the world. So the world is already seen at this point as a machine. And if the world is a machine, then in order to, and they say that if you can understand the mind of a craftsman by looking at the machine that he makes and therefore you can understand the mind of God
也非常不完整。例如，我们只知道伯里圣埃德蒙兹修道院（Bury St Edmunds Abbey）在 1198 年有一个水钟，因为他们用那个水钟里的水来扑灭了一场火灾。所以，如果当时没有发生火灾……绝对的，我的意思是，那是最近的水源……所以，如果在伯里圣埃德蒙兹没有发生火灾，我们甚至不会知道那里有一个水钟……所以，是的，诺维奇是我们知道他们有钟的一个地方，因为我们有更换钟时的账目……而且在圣奥尔本斯，他们确实拥有世界上第一座复杂的机械钟，是由修道院院长理查德·沃灵福德（Richard of Wallingford）在 1320 年代末到 1330 年代初设计的。那座钟不仅仅能报时，它还能显示潮汐，甚至可能显示行星，还能计算……
by looking at creation so if you can sort of reproduce the cosmos in a box then you can go some way towards understanding the component parts of it and thereby understanding God so there is a kind of theological motivation for this plus of course there, of course, it's a way of demonstrating your power and your control. And this is where clocks pass quite quickly from their invention around the end of the 13th century. By the 15th century, we're seeing clocks in town halls and in civic buildings, non-religious buildings, where they become a kind of way for local authorities to show their power, to show their control. You know, you put a clock on your town hall in Strasbourg or Burgh.
日食，所以那确实是一个宇宙的模型。我们休息一下吧，汤姆。是的，我们休息一下。你应该去想想索尔兹伯里大教堂的钟。我要在一个盒子里重现宇宙。然后，我们会回来的。而且我回来时会带有一个非常好的问题。所以请收听。好的。非常令人兴奋。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一抹八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告的收听体验、加更节目以及现场门票的优先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。
Where are the clocks invented? Is it Norwich? So, as I say, we don't have the earliest surviving clocks because they were all melted down or recycled or destroyed or replaced. But we have early records of clocks in the 1270s and 80s in many of the cathedrals and abbeys around England, but they were probably also in other parts of Europe as well. And it's tricky because, of course, there were water clocks, there were sundials course there were water clocks there were sundials there were other forms of timekeeping technology and since we only have written records um when they say clock we don't know exactly whether it's a mechanical clock or a water clock or something else uh and the records
汤姆·霍兰确实一直在思考索尔兹伯里大教堂的钟，而我也确实在一个盒子里造出了宇宙，这证明了我的力量。现在，塞布·福尔克和我们在一起，他正在谈论中世纪科学。在休息之前，我们讨论了钟表、摆弄小玩意儿，以及人们……你知道的，在多大程度上在做——我想我们现在非常宽泛地称之为科学的事情。我的问题，塞布，是关于进步的。显然，我们的科学叙事中有很大一部分是基于进步的概念——站在巨人的肩膀上，我们之前提到过这一点，每次都建造得越来越宏大。所以你有了牛顿，然后是他的继承人，以此类推，直到爱因斯坦。这就是故事。你知道，这是一个故事。他们对类似的事情有概念吗？他们对朝向某种更大启蒙的进步叙事有什么概念吗？简短的回答是“没有”，因为……根据基督教的故事，一切在伊甸园之后都衰落了，基本上就是这样。因此，如果你问一个基督教学者，他们会说他们试图做的是保存古代知识，并在其基础上进行建设，试图重新定义它，试图理解它。但他们很多时候的感受是，他们永远无法恢复伊甸园的完美智慧。所以在那个堕落的故事中，有一种复杂性，即：“好吧，如果没有它，我们就不会有今天。”然而，
are pretty partial so for example we only know that there was a water clock in barry st edmund's abbey in 1198 because they used the water from the water clock to put out a fire so if there hadn't been a fire absolutely i mean it was the nearest source of water so uh so if there hadn't been a fire in barry st edmunds then we wouldn't even know they had a water clock there um so yeah norwich is is one place where we know that they had a clock because we have the accounts uh for when the clock was replaced um and uh and uh in st albans they had really the world's first complex mechanical clock which was designed by the abbot Richard of Wallingford in the late 1320s early 1330s and that did much more than tell the time that that showed you the tides and it maybe even showed you the planets and it computed
我们永远无法回到那个完美的时代。所以他们并不觉得自己取得了完美的进步，但这并不意味着在实际层面上，他们学不到东西，发现不了新事物，也无法了解别人所知道的东西。但关于进步，问题的一部分还在于，这取决于你如何定义进步，以及什么才算作进步。
eclipses so that really is a model of the universe let's take a break Tom yeah let's take a break you should go and think about the clock in Salisbury. I'm going to reproduce the cosmos in a box. And, and then we'll come back in. And I've got a very good question to come back in with. So stay tuned. Yes. All right. Very exciting. See you back in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde, and I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
日食，所以这确实是一个宇宙的模型，我们休息一下吧，汤姆。好的，我们休息一下，你应该去想想索尔兹伯里的时钟，而我要在一个盒子里面重现整个宇宙。然后我们会回来，我有一个非常好的问题要在回来时提出，所以请继续收听。好的，非常令人兴奋，一会见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点秀场八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告的节目、额外剧集以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com，网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史之巅》。
Tom Holland has indeed been thinking about the clock in Salisbury, and I have indeed made the cosmos in a box which is testimony to my power. Now, Seb Fulk is with us, and he's talking about medieval science. And before the break, we were talking about clocks and tinkering and the extent to which people you know were doing i suppose what we would very loosely now call science my question seb is about progress so obviously so much of our sense of a scientific narrative is based on the idea of progress of standing on the shoulders of giants which we alluded to before and building
汤姆·霍兰德确实一直在思考索尔兹伯里的时钟，而我也确实在一个盒子里面制作了宇宙，这证明了我的能力。现在，塞布·福尔克和我们在一起，他正在谈论中世纪科学。在休息之前，我们在讨论时钟和修理，以及人们在多大程度上，你知道的，我猜在做我们现在非常宽泛地称之为科学的事情。我的问题，塞布，是关于进步的，很明显，我们对科学叙事的很多理解都基于进步的概念，基于站在巨人的肩膀上——我们之前提到过——并且每一次都建造得更大，
something bigger and bigger every time so you have newton and then you have his successors and so on and so on you get to einstein that's the story you know it is a story did they have a sense of something like that do they have any sense of there being a progressive narrative towards greater enlightenment as it were the the short answer is no because uh according to the christian story everything was declined after the Garden of Eden, basically. And so if you asked a Christian scholar, they would say that what they were trying to do was to preserve ancient knowledge and to build on it and to try and redefine it and to try and understand it. But the sense that they had a lot of the time was that they would never be able to reclaim the perfect wisdom of the Garden of Eden. So in that story of the fall, there is a sort of complexity of, well, we couldn't be where we are without it. And yet,
变得越来越宏大，所以有了牛顿，然后是他的继承者，诸如此类，直到爱因斯坦，这就是你所知道的故事。他们对类似的事情有什么概念吗？他们对于向着某种更高启蒙的进步叙事有什么概念吗？简短的回答是“没有”，因为根据基督教的故事，基本上自伊甸园之后一切都在走下坡路。因此，如果你问一个基督教学者，他们会说他们试图做的是保存古代知识，并在其基础上进行建设，试图重新定义它并试图理解它。但他们很多时候的感受是，他们永远无法恢复伊甸园的完美智慧。所以在那个堕落的故事中，有一种复杂性，那就是：没有它我们就无法到达今天的地步，然而，
we will never be able to sort of go back to that perfect time. So they didn't have a sense that they were making perfect progress, but that didn't mean that in practical terms, they couldn't learn things and they couldn't discover new things and they couldn't find out what other people knew. But the part of the problem with progress also is that it depends on what you define as progress and what counts as progress.
我们永远无法回到那个完美的时代。因此，他们没有那种认为自己正在取得完美进步的观念，但这并不意味着在实际层面上，他们不能学习新事物，不能发现新事物，也不能了解其他人所知道的事情。但是，进步的问题的一部分还在于，这取决于你如何定义进步以及什么才算作进步。
So they might've thought about progress in moral terms. And, you know, how can we become better people and how can we know God better? And that was something that they could perhaps achieve in their own minds. So I think part of the problem is that we assume that we all agree on what progress is and that humanity must make some sort of linear progression. And that isn't the case in history in the sense of, well, sometimes knowledge has gone backwards. And also we haven't always agreed
所以他们对进步的理解可能是从道德的层面出发的。比如，我们怎样才能成为更好的人，怎样才能更好地认识上帝？这或许是他们在自己心中就能实现的事情。所以我觉得部分问题在于，我们想当然地认为大家对什么是进步都有共识，并且人类必须经历某种线性的发展。但在历史中事实并非如此，因为有时知识反而是倒退的。而且，对于最初什么才算作进步，
on what counts as progress to begin with. But we define progress, don't we, very much as mastery over nature. You know, we can transcend the limits of the natural world. But they presumably didn't have a sense of that in the same way well certainly their nature was one in which god intervened on a daily basis um and so there were limitations to what humans could know and what humans could do and i think it's very important i suppose uh to emphasize that they that they wanted to be modest
我们其实也并未达成始终如一的共识。然而，我们对进步的定义，很大程度上就是指对自然的征服。你看，我们可以超越自然世界的局限。但他们大概不会以这种方式来看待这个问题——当然，在他们的世界观里，上帝是每天都会进行干预的，因此人类能知道什么、能做什么都是有限制的。而且我认为，强调他们对自然保持谦逊的态度，
about about nature in the sense of, well, in some sense, it wasn't really for humans to try and be gods, essentially, to set themselves up as gods. But they have a spark of the divine reason, don't they? The lux hominem. Yeah. So it is a tension. It is a tension.
这一点非常重要，也就是说，在某种意义上，人类本质上并不应该试图去扮演上帝，或者把自己塑造成上帝。但他们身上确实带有神圣理性的火花，对吧？也就是所谓的“人类之光”。是的。所以这是一种张力。这确实是一种张力。
I think one of the things that we have to get away from is this idea that medieval people agreed about everything and constantly behaved in a consistent way. Neither of those things are true. So they can say we have to be modest in our ambitions to understand God because we could never understand God and it would be blasphemous even to think that we could. Yet appearing in all of their actions that they spent all of their time trying to understand God
我认为我们需要摆脱的一个观念是：中世纪的人在所有事情上都意见一致，并且总是表现出一种前后一致的行为方式。这两点其实都不是真的。一方面，他们会说我们在企图理解上帝时必须抱有谦逊的态度，因为我们永远无法理解上帝，甚至只要有这种想法都是一种亵渎。然而从他们的种种行为来看，他们却似乎把所有时间都用来试图理解上帝，
and trying to understand God through nature, which was a very clear principle of something that could be done. So there are contradictions there. And so also, do you think the Christian idea of God is that he's all-powerful, that he's created everything? So there is the sense of the universe as a kind of a coherent entity that perhaps in other ways of understanding the cosmos you don't necessarily get. And on top of that, Christianity has this idea that God
并且试图通过自然来理解上帝，这是当时被认为切实可行的一个明确原则。所以这其中存在着矛盾。那么，你认为基督教对上帝的理解是否涵盖了他是全能的、创造了一切的？因此，宇宙在某种程度上被视为一个连贯的实体，这种看法或许在理解宇宙的其他方式中并不常见。除此之外，基督教还有一个观念，那就是上帝
subjects himself to covenants. So he has a covenant with Moses, he kind of signs up to that. And whatever exactly it is the crucifixion, what's going on there, there is a sense that some way, there's some kind of agreement that's being drawn up. So do you think that that implies that both that God is all powerful, but that he is happy to construct laws that perhaps humans can fathom, and that therefore there's a kind of theological framework for what we would now see as, you know, the attempt to work out laws that underpin the running of the universe. Yeah, that's right. There is even a tension there though, right? Because the physicists, you know, followers of Aristotle, try to understand the universe in the terms in which Aristotle put it, and try and explain kind of what is and isn't possible according to the laws
会让自己受制于圣约。所以他和摩西订立了契约，他某种程度上认可了这一点。不管钉十字架的具体含义到底是什么，总之在某种意义上，似乎有一种协议正在被达成。所以你认为这是否意味着，一方面上帝是全能的，但另一方面他也乐于制定人类能够理解的法律，因此，这就为我们现在所理解的“试图找出支撑宇宙运行的规律”提供了一种神学框架？是的，确实如此。不过这里面其实也存在一种张力，对吧？因为物理学家们——也就是亚里士多德的信奉者——试图按照亚里士多德提出的框架去理解宇宙，并试图根据物理学定律
of physics. And that to us makes a lot of sense. isn't possible according to the laws of physics. And that to us makes a lot of sense. But if you talk about the laws of physics, then the theologians might get a little bit tense and antsy about constraining the power of God. So you get these arguments in the 13th century about whether it's possible to have a vacuum in nature. And the consensus was that a vacuum couldn't exist. But the theologians say, well, you can't stop God making a vacuum. Because that's just constraining the power of God.
来解释什么可能发生、什么不可能发生。这在我们看来是完全合乎情理的。但这在我们看来是完全合乎情理的。然而，如果你开始谈论物理学定律，神学家们可能会感到有点紧张和不安，因为他们觉得这限制了上帝的权力。所以在13世纪，你会看到这样的争论：自然界中是否可能存在真空？当时的共识是真空是不可能存在的。但神学家们会说，嗯，你不能阻止上帝创造一个真空，因为那简直就是在限制上帝的权力。
So it's not that God has made a vacuum or that God is going to make a vacuum, but that if God feels like making a vacuum, he can now walk out. It's a strange thing to do with your day, right? Yeah, but he's gone. Yeah, I guess so. He moves in mysterious ways. But Seb, you mentioned Aristotle. And kind of on the idea of progress, I guess one of the ways in which people in medieval Europe do feel a sense of progress
所以这并不是说上帝已经制造了一个真空，或者上帝打算制造一个真空，而是说如果上帝哪天心情好想制造一个真空，他完全可以做到。花一天时间去琢磨这个挺奇怪的，对吧？对，但他已经走了。好吧，我想是吧。上帝的意图总是莫测高深。不过塞布，你刚才提到了亚里士多德。关于进步这个概念，我想中世纪欧洲人之所以能感受到某种意义上的进步，
is actually that they're kind of fathoming this ancient wisdom that you talked about. Because they live in a world where Aristotle for much of the early Middle Ages is not really known. And then through Byzantium, through the Islamic Spain, they get the opportunity to discover Aristotle. And you're brilliant in your book at talking about what a kind of bombshell effect this is. So can you just try and explain why Aristotle kind of has this impact? Because, you know, I mean, he's not a Christian, he's a Greek philosopher. What is the way that he kind of impacts on the Christian world in medieval Europe? So Aristotle was the ultimate polymath. I mean, he observed animals, so he would creep up on sea urchins to see if they behaved differently when they thought they were being watched from
其实是因为他们正在逐渐参透你所提到的这种古代智慧。因为在早中世纪的很大一部分时间里，他们生活在一个并不太了解亚里士多德的世界里。后来通过拜占庭和伊斯兰统治下的西班牙，他们才有机会重新发现亚里士多德。你的书里非常精彩地探讨了这带来了怎样一种“重磅炸弹”般的效果。所以你能否解释一下，为什么亚里士多德会产生这样的影响力？因为，你知道的，他并不是基督徒，而是一位希腊哲学家。他是如何对中世纪欧洲的基督教世界产生影响的呢？所以，亚里士多德堪称终极的博学家。我的意思是，他会观察动物，他会蹑手蹑脚地靠近海胆，去观察它们在以为自己被监视和
when they didn't think they were. And he understood the fundamental laws of physics and tried to bring time and motion together in a single law. And so for medieval people, the scale of his ambition was tremendously daunting. But his texts were very hard to get into, because not only were they not really written to be read, they were really notes from lectures, but also they'd been translated through Syriac and Arabic and often Castilian Spanish, and so they were extremely hard to understand. So medieval people spent a huge amount of time just trying to get their heads around the works of Aristotle. But to them there was a kind of a sense that there was hidden knowledge here, and there was a kind of deeper level of explanation than they'd ever encountered before and part of the problem is is that aristotle
没有被监视时行为是否会有所不同。他理解物理学的基本定律，并试图将时间和运动统一到一个单一的定律中。因此，对中世纪的人来说，他的雄心壮志的规模是极其令人生畏的。但他的著作非常难懂，因为它们不仅本身就不是为了阅读而写的，基本上只是演讲的笔记，而且它们还经过了叙利亚语、阿拉伯语以及卡斯蒂利亚西班牙语的层层翻译，所以极其难以理解。因此，中世纪的人花了大量的时间来试图弄懂亚里士多德的著作。但在他们看来，这里面似乎蕴含着某种隐藏的知识，并且有一种比他们以往接触过的任何解释都更为深层的解释。不过部分问题在于，亚里士多德
says that that everything has always existed and so there's no kind of genesis right so i mean that's a that's a pretty firm statement that he makes that is very hard for christians to get around and simply uh that's that's one that they can dismiss because, you know, yes, Aristotle says the universe is eternal, but that clearly conflicts with the principle of biblical creation. And so Christians simply have to say, no, Aristotle is wrong about that. So they're not, you know, they're not averse to saying that Aristotle is wrong about something. I think sometimes it's a cliche about the Middle Ages that the scholastics are slaves to Aristotle and just spend all of their time reading Aristotle and studying Aristotle and never go anywhere beyond Aristotle, which of course it is possible to do. But that's not the case because they do point out places in which
认为万物一直都是存在的，所以这里面没有类似于创世记的概念，对吧？我的意思是，他做出了一个非常明确的断言，而这一点是基督徒很难绕过去的。不过，简单来说，这并不是他们可以轻易驳回的一点，因为，没错，亚里士多德说宇宙是永恒的，但这显然与《圣经》中创世的原则相冲突。因此，基督徒不得不直截了当地指出，亚里士多德在这点上是错的。所以他们并不是那种……你知道的，他们并不排斥指出亚里士多德在某些事情上是错的。我认为关于中世纪经常有一个陈词滥调，即经院学者们是亚里士多德的奴隶，整天只知道阅读和研究亚里士多德，从来不敢超越亚里士多德半步，而这当然是可以做到的。但事实并非如此，因为他们的确指出了在某些方面
he is, according to them, clearly mistaken. But in general, they spend a lot of time working through his ideas and understanding the implications of him. And famously, he's called the philosopher because he is the ultimate authority in that sense to them. Seb, you mentioned translations from Arabic and so on, and when you were talking about Aristotle and the transmission of Aristotle. And we had a question about this from Diogo Morgado, who I have to say has been on fire in recent weeks with this question. He really is, isn't he, singing?
按照他们的看法，亚里士多德显然是弄错了。但总的来说，他们花了大量时间来钻研他的思想并理解其蕴含的意义。而且众所周知，他被称为“哲学家”，因为对他们而言，他是那个意义上的终极权威。塞布，刚才你提到了从阿拉伯语等的翻译，以及你在谈论亚里士多德和亚里士多德思想的传播时的情况。我们收到了来自迪奥戈·莫尔加多（Diogo Morgado）关于这个问题的提问，我必须说，他最近几周对这类问题简直是热情高涨。他真的是状态火热，对吧？
He says, shouldn't we be talking about medieval Islamic science? Because that's where the most advanced research was conducted at the time. Cordoba and Baghdad were so much more ahead than anywhere else, right? Well, is that right? And should we be talking about medieval Islamic science rather than Christians necessarily? Yeah, well, yes. It's undoubtedly the case that in the high Middle Ages,
他说，难道我们不应该多谈谈中世纪的伊斯兰科学吗？因为当时最先进的研究正是在那里进行的。科尔多瓦和巴格达比世界上任何其他地方都要先进得多，对吧？嗯，真的是这样吗？我们是不是应该多谈谈中世纪的伊斯兰科学，而不是一味聚焦于基督徒？嗯，是的，确实如此。毫无疑问，在盛期中世纪，
the Islamic world was a centre for science. And that's basically because science proceeds ultimately through processes of communication. And the Islamic world was, in a sense, at the centre of the civilised world. So they took ideas from ancient Greece and translated them into Arabic. They took ideas from India. And you get scholars from Central Asia coming to Baghdad, the center of the Abbasid Caliphate in the 8th and 9th centuries, translating all these ideas, studying them, copying huge numbers of books, and developing these ideas. And the Islamic world gives us scholars like Al-Kindi,
伊斯兰世界确实是科学的中心。这主要是因为科学的发展归根结底依赖于交流的过程。而从某种意义上说，伊斯兰世界正处于文明世界的中心。他们吸收了古希腊的思想并将其翻译成阿拉伯语。他们吸收了来自印度的思想。你会看到来自中亚的学者们来到巴格达——即8、9世纪阿拔斯王朝的中心，将所有这些思想翻译过来、进行研究、大量抄写书籍，并进一步发展这些思想。伊斯兰世界为我们涌现出了诸如肯迪、
Avicenna, Ibn al-Haytham, some names that are famous and other names that deserve to be better known. So yes, absolutely, the Islamic world was at the centre of things. I mean, amazing detail from your book about John of Westwick, who begins, I think, have I got this right, that he begins his text, in the name of God, pittus and merciful, which is obviously the bismillah, the Islamic formula referring to God, that you've got that echo coming all the way through, presumably, I guess, through Spain up into St. Albans. And that's kind of an amazing tribute to what an international project this is. Yeah, absolutely. And of course, you know, there are many words, many modern scientific words that go back to Arabic and Arabic culture. Algorithm famously comes from al-Khwarizmi,
阿维森纳、海什木等学者，其中有一些名字家喻户晓，而另一些名字则同样值得被更多人了解。所以，是的，毫无疑问，伊斯兰世界当时确实处于核心地位。我的意思是，你的书中有一个关于韦斯特维克的约翰（John of Westwick）的惊人细节，他开篇写道——如果我没记错的话——他的文本是以“奉至仁至慈的真主之名”开始的，这显然就是“泰斯米”（Bismillah），即伊斯兰教中指代真主的颂词。这种回响一直延续了下来，大概是通过西班牙一直传到了圣奥尔本斯。这简直是对这样一个国际化项目的一曲惊人赞歌。是的，完全如此。而且当然了，你知道，有很多现代科学词汇都可以追溯到阿拉伯语和阿拉伯文化。例如，“算法”（Algorithm）这个词就源自阿尔·花剌子密（al-Khwarizmi），
the man who brought the Hindu Arabic numerals from India to the Arabic speaking world. And, you know, things like algebra and so on. So Arabic culture is infused in our science even today. What's interesting about that quotation from John Westwick is that early readers of that manuscript thought that this was evidence that he was translating an original Arabic text. And it's possible that's true, but I suspect it's actually because it's a kind of literary flourish. He thinks scientific texts start with Bismillahirrahmanirrahim. That's how they begin. Yes, that's just what you do. So I'm going to do the same. And he does it in Middle English, which is unusual. And astrolabes, do they come to the medieval world, to the European world through Spain as well?
正是他将印度的印度-阿拉伯数字引入了阿拉伯语世界。还有诸如“代数”（Algebra）等等。因此，即使在今天，阿拉伯文化依然融入在我们的科学之中。关于约翰·韦斯特维克引文的有趣之处在于，该手稿的早期读者曾认为，这是他在翻译阿拉伯语原创文本的证据。这或许是真的，但我怀疑其实这只是一种文学修饰。他认为科学文本就是应该以“奉至仁至慈的真主之名”开头。它们就是这样开头的。是的，这就是常规操作。所以我也要这么做。而且他还是用中古英语写的，这很不寻常。那么星盘呢？它们也是通过西班牙传入中世纪世界、传入欧洲世界的吗？
Yes. Well, yes. So the principles of the astrolabe were what is an astrolabe that's that's it's a kind of it's a it shows you the workings of the universe basically uh I mean the word means kind of star finder um I've got one here I shall wave it at my microphone so listeners can at least hear it even if they can't see it good sound effects podcasting yeah absolutely um and it's a brass disc it fits in the palm of your hand it's multifunctional uh so in some senses it's like a medieval smartphone in that it looks cool um you can make people jealous with it but you can also do a bunch of really interesting things with it uh such as tell the time work out the hard to work out the height of a building
是的。嗯，是的。星盘的原理是——究竟什么是星盘？它其实是一种……它基本上能向你展示宇宙的运作方式。我的意思是，这个词的意思有点像“寻星器”。我这里正好有一个，我要在麦克风前晃一晃，这样听众们即使看不见至少也能听到它的声音。不错的音响效果，播客就是这样，对吧？完全正确。它是一个黄铜盘子，刚好能放在手掌心，具有多种功能。所以从某种意义上说，它就像是中世纪的智能手机，因为看起来很酷，
so when abelard and eloise call their their son uhrolabe, it's kind of like calling it iPhone. Yeah, pretty much. Yeah. Wow. I mean, you know, it's nothing that Elon Musk couldn't beat. So, yeah, it's a sort of multifunctional device. And basically it's anything. It's a model of the universe.
你可以用它来让人羡慕嫉妒恨，但你也可以用它做很多非常有趣的事情，比如报时、计算建筑的高度。
So you can tell the time with it. You can work out when a certain star is going to rise or you can work out which way is north all of these sorts of things with an astrolabe and it's a piece of design it's a it's a kind of beautiful object and a status symbol um so those the principles of of projection essentially putting the spherical universe onto a flat disc are laid out by Ptolemy the ancient Greek astronomer in Alexandria in the second century AD. But we don't know for sure whether he ever made one. And then we get late ancient Greek texts from people like Theon of Alexandria later on saying, you know, this is how you make an astrolabe in practice. But the earliest astrolabes that we have are from the Islamic world.
所以当阿伯拉尔和爱洛伊丝给他们的儿子取名为“星盘”（Astrolabe）时，这就有点像给他取名叫“iPhone”一样。对，差不多就是这样。哇。我的意思是，这绝对是埃隆·马斯克也无法超越的。所以，是的，这是一种多功能设备。基本上它什么都能做，它就是宇宙的一个模型。
And as you say, they come into medieval Europe through Muslim Spain, where they are kind of refined and adapted and made to suit Christian purposes. So the designs are adapted and shifted, but the basic principles are unchanged. Coming to an end and kind of drawing on that sense of a vast hinterland of knowledge that people in Europe are drawing on, but also the way in which perhaps the medieval becomes the early modern.
所以你可以用它来报时，可以计算出某颗恒星何时升起，或者用星盘确定哪个方向是北方，诸如此类。它是一件精心设计的产品，是一个美丽的物件，也是身份的象征。因此，这种投影的原理——本质上是将球形的宇宙呈现在一个扁平的圆盘上——是由公元2世纪亚历山大的古希腊天文学家托勒密首次阐明的。但我们并不确定他是否真的亲手制作过一个。后来我们看到了晚期古希腊学者的文本，比如稍后时期的亚历山大的塞翁（Theon of Alexandria），他们在书中写道：“你看，这就是在实践中制作星盘的方法。”然而，现存最早的星盘却来自于伊斯兰世界。
Could we just look at Copernicus who in your book you cast as someone who is drawing on what a kind of central Asian tradition of thinking about the the earth as being at the center sorry the sun being the center of the universe and the earth going around the sun and this is and is that sense I mean is that a radical break with what's gone before or is it an expression of continuity, do you think? I'd say it's probably more an expression of continuity. Certainly Copernicus is concerned to present it in those terms, in the preface that he writes as a form of a letter to the Pope.
正如你所说，它们通过穆斯林统治下的西班牙进入了中世纪的欧洲，在那里它们得到了改进、调整和改造，以适应基督教的需求。因此，其设计被调整和改变了，但基本原理保持不变。接下来我们要接近尾声了，我想探讨一下欧洲人所汲取的这种庞大的知识腹地，以及中世纪如何逐渐过渡到早期现代。
So he's in the 16th century, isn't he? And he's drawing on stuff from Central Asia. I mean, has that got that right? Well, yes and no so uh the the ideas that the earth might be um going around the sun rather than the reverse um is is found in uh ancient european sources is found in um roman and greek sources it's suggested uh and copernicus goes back to those a true renaissance man that he's going back to the classical sources to try to find other people who have thought what he thinks in the past as a kind of support for his assumptions. So in that sense he's a true medieval, he's trying to look for
我们能谈谈哥白尼吗？在你的书中，你将他塑造成这样一个人：他汲取了中亚关于宇宙中心思想的传统——抱歉，是以太阳为宇宙中心、地球绕着太阳转的传统。这是一种与过去彻底决裂的激进变革，还是你认为它是某种连续性的体现？我想说，这可能更多是连续性的体现。当然，哥白尼在作为给教皇的信件前言中，也刻意以这种方式来表达自己的观点。
authorities to back up his ideas. The geometry that he uses to make it work, that comes from the Islamic world, that comes from Central Asia And so he draws on a bunch of scholars, most notably At-Tusi, who was Persian in the 14th century. Oh, Ali Ansari would be thrilled to hear that. It's all Persian. Well, there's a whole bunch of them, Al-Urdiya, Shirazi, you know, from across the Islamic world. And it's argued still by historians
所以他生活在16世纪，对吧？而他汲取的是来自中亚的资料。我的意思是，我没记错吧？嗯，对也不对。所以……地球可能围绕着太阳转而不是相反的这种思想，其实在古代欧洲的来源中就能找到，在罗马和希腊的源头中也有提及、有过暗示。而哥白尼正是回溯到了这些源头。他是一个真正的文艺复兴人，他回到古典文献中去寻找过去是否有其他人持有和他相同的观点，以此来为自己的假设寻找支撑。所以从这个意义上说，他是一个地道的中世纪人，他一直在试图寻找
how much Copernicus depends on them versus independently discovering these geometrical models. But he basically has to make it work geometrically. He starts with this idea where he thinks that actually it's the sun that's at the centre of the universe, not the earth. He sticks to the idea of perfect circles. So he can't make it work because the universe doesn't operate in perfect circles but Copernicus maintains this basic principle that motion in the heavens should be in in perfect circles and so he ends up with a system that is basically just as complicated as the one that he started with but replaces isn't it I mean it's it's not just as complicated but it's also as unprovable yeah and there are clear
权威来支持自己的观点。而他用来让这一切得以成立的几何学，则来自于伊斯兰世界，来自于中亚。因此，他借鉴了一批学者，其中最著名的是14世纪的波斯学者纳西尔丁·图西（At-Tusi）。哦，阿里·安萨里（Ali Ansari）听到这个一定会高兴坏的。全都是波斯人！嗯，其实还有一大批人，比如乌尔迪（Al-Urdiya）、设拉子（Shirazi），他们来自整个伊斯兰世界。至今历史学家们仍在争论
objections to Copernicus's theories most obviously the fact that if we're moving through the universe at thousands of miles an hour, why do we not feel the wind rushing past our ears? And if we are moving thousands of miles in the course of a year, why do we not observe any parallax in the stars? And those questions weren't resolved for a long time after Copernicus was writing in the early 16th century. So there were objections to him at the time.
哥白尼究竟在多大程度上依赖了他们，还是说他独立发现了这些几何模型。但他基本上必须让它在几何上行得通。他从这样一个理念开始：他认为实际上太阳才是宇宙的中心，而不是地球。但他仍然坚持完美圆周的理念。所以他的模型最终还是行不通，因为宇宙并不是按照完美的圆周运行的，但哥白尼坚持了这样一个基本原则：天体的运动应当是完美的圆周。因此，他最终构建出的系统，其复杂程度基本上和他的起点不相上下，而且它取代了……不是吗？我的意思是，它不仅同样复杂，而且同样无法证明，对吧？的确，当时对哥白尼的理论存在着清晰的反对意见，
Those objections were voiced very clearly by scholars who were equally, if not more eminent than him. And other models were proposed, most notably that of Tycho Brahe in Denmark, who proposed that essentially all the planets went around the sun except the earth. The sun goes around the earth. So that also, in fact, that explains the phenomena that we observe better than Copernicus's model. So what we see in the 16th century is this constant argument, this back and forth, and that is the basis of science, really. It's the argument, not this idea of some great person coming up with the right answer and everybody else immediately falls into line. Seb, is this the point where medieval science as it were is coming to an end
最显而易见的反对意见是：如果我们以每小时数千英里的速度在宇宙中穿行，为什么我们感觉不到呼呼的风声从耳边掠过？如果我们每年在太空中移动数千英里，为什么我们在恒星中观察不到任何视差？这些问题在16世纪初哥白尼写作之后的很长一段时间里都没有得到解决。所以在当时，人们对他的观点是存在异议的。
and we're moving into some new phase so obviously you know our sense of time is much as we like to complicate it we do divide it into kind of blocks is this the sort of 15th century Copernicus and then getting into the the sort of early period. Is that a definite shift, as you see it, in our scientific history? Well, there definitely is a change that takes place, but it's very gradual. And most people would sort of put it in the 17th century, sometime between Galileo and Kepler and the end of Newton's career at the beginning of the 18th century. What we see in Copernicus is definitely a shift because he's taking advantage of the new medium of printing to exchange ideas. But he also, as I already said, in his kind of looking back to earlier authorities, is a real Renaissance man. And his
这些异议是由那些名气不亚于他、甚至比他更大的学者们明确表达出来的。并且人们还提出了其他模型，最著名的当属丹麦的第谷·布拉赫（Tycho Brahe），他提出基本上所有行星都绕着太阳转，唯独地球例外，太阳则绕着地球转。因此，这甚至能比哥白尼的模型更好地解释我们所观察到的现象。所以我们在16世纪看到的是这种不断的争论、反复的拉扯，而这其实正是科学的基础。科学正是建立在争论之上的，而不是建立在“某位伟人得出正确答案，然后其他人立刻随声附和”这种观念之上。塞布，这是否意味着中世纪科学即将走向尾声，
De Revolutionibus, his book in which he presents his heliocentric theory, is modelled very closely on Ptolemy's Almagest. So he is self-consciously presenting himself in some sense as medieval. But that's a sensible way to promote your ideas, really, because if you want people to take something controversial and understand it, you have to present it in terms that they're going to accept. What we see later is a whole shift in ideas. And part of that is a kind of valorization of the new and original, which some people have associated with the European discovery of what they call the new world, as a kind of way of proving that actually something new, we can know something new that the ancients didn't know about. But also there's a kind of increase in experimentation, an increase in inductive
而我们正迈向一个新的阶段？很显然，尽管我们喜欢把时间复杂化，但我们确实习惯把它划分成不同的区块。那么15世纪的哥白尼以及随之而来的早期阶段，在你看来，这是我们科学史上一个明确的转折点吗？嗯，这其中确实发生了变化，但这是一个非常渐进的过程。大多数人会把这个转折点放在17世纪，大约介于伽利略、开普勒与牛顿生涯结束、18世纪初之间。我们在哥白尼身上确实看到了一个转变，因为他利用了印刷术这种新媒介来交流思想。但正如我刚才所说的那样，他在回溯早期权威这一点上，又是一个彻头彻尾的文艺复兴人。他的
knowledge, observing nature and not worrying too much about whether your observations were the same as what somebody else might observe, which was always a stumbling block in the Middle Ages, this idea that our senses were fallible and therefore we couldn't rely too much on our own observations but you could say couldn't you that you know this process of experimentation that some of the areas that we now regard as as absolutely not science of astrology or alchemy or whatever that that is you know testing to find out whether they work or not is a process of experimentation and that in a sense the kind of line that becomes by the 19th century, what we would now call science. I mean, we arrive at that through a process
《天体运行论》（De Revolutionibus）——也就是他阐述日心说的著作——在很大程度上是以托勒密的《大宪章》（Almagest，应为《天文学大成》）为模板的。所以他在某种意义上有意识地将自己表现为中世纪风格。但从宣传自己思想的角度来看，这其实是一种明智的做法，因为如果你想让人们接受并理解某些充满争议的东西，你就必须用他们能够接受的术语来表达。而我们后来看到的，则是思想上的整体转变。其中一部分是对新奇事物和原创性的推崇，一些人将这与欧洲人发现所谓“新世界”联系起来，以此作为证明我们确实能够了解古人所不知道的新事物的途径。但与此同时，实验活动也有所增加，归纳法知识不断丰富，人们开始观察自然，而不再过分担心自己的观察结果是否与别人的一致——这在中世纪一直是个绊脚石，因为当时人们认为我们的感官是不可靠的，因此不能过分依赖自身的观察。不过你也可以说，对吧？这种实验的过程——我们现在认为绝对不属于科学的某些领域，比如占星术、炼金术等等——其实正是在通过测试来验证它们是否奏效，这本身就是一个实验的过程。从某种意义上说，到了19世纪，演变成我们现在所称的“科学”的这条线，
of testing other approaches to knowledge. Yeah, it's all about how systematic it is, right? Because experimentum in Latin just means experience. It just means something that happens to you. And so this process of experiment morphing into something that is a discrete moment in time, into something that you design, something that you carry out and you might do multiple times in order to check it, that's something that happens gradually over time from this medieval idea that experiment is just an experience that you had
正是通过测试其他获取知识的方法而逐步形成的。是的，关键在于它的系统性有多强，对吧？因为拉丁语中的“experimentum”仅仅意味着“经验”。它只意味着发生在你身上的事情。因此，实验这个过程逐渐演变成一个时间上独立的、由你设计、由你执行、并且你可以多次重复以进行验证的环节。这个过程随着时间推移逐渐从那种中世纪的观念中演变而来——在中世纪，实验仅仅意味着你经历过的事情，
that maybe happened to you rather than something that you did. So we can't really ever say one person invented experiment it's an idea that evolved over time but basically we could say i mean just to kind of draw a line under it we could say monks yay for monks well they're not the baddies i mean the whole point the whole point about uh copernicus right is that he is a sort of symptom of an increase in knowledge that the universe is not operating as we want it to to do and so astronomers over centuries noticed that the models of Ptolemy didn't quite match up to reality it was just a kind of question of how content they were with the imperfection and it's it's an increase in in experience it's an increase in calculation it's
它可能只是发生在你身上，而不是你主动去完成的事情。所以我们真的不能说某一个人发明了实验，这是一个随时间演变的理念。但基本上我们可以说——为了给这个话题做个总结——我们可以说：僧侣万岁！好吧，他们并不是反派。我的意思是，关于哥白尼的核心要点在于，他其实是知识不断增长的一种症状，这表明宇宙并没有按照我们期望的那样运转。因此，几个世纪以来的天文学家们注意到，托勒密的模型并不能完全与现实吻合，问题仅仅在于他们对这种不完美有多大程度的容忍。这是经验的积累，是计算能力的增长，是
an increase in all the things that medieval people did that allows them to say, no, this isn't good enough. We need a better system. So it relies on that medieval practice, even if it takes a little bit longer for somebody to come up with an alternative that works better.
中世纪人们所做的一切努力的积累，正是这一切让他们得以说：“不，这还不够好。我们需要一个更好的系统。”因此，它依赖于中世纪的实践，尽管可能需要更长的时间才会有人提出一个效果更好的替代方案。
Brilliant. Well, thanks so much. And your book, The Light Ages, is great. I read it in proof and then I read it again yesterday to prepare for this and I enjoyed it just as much the second time as the first. So, rush out and
太棒了。非常感谢。你的书《光明时代》（The Light Ages）非常棒。我先是读了校样，昨天为了做准备又读了一遍，第二次读获得的乐趣和第一次一样多。所以大家快去
buy it, guys, because it bears definitely a second reading. Thanks so much, Seb. Thanks, everyone, to listening. We will be back soon with... What are we going to be doing? We don't know. We haven't decided yet. Something. Something. Experimental process. Yeah, we need to
买一本吧，因为这本书绝对值得二刷。非常感谢，塞布。也谢谢大家的聆听。我们很快就会回来……我们要聊点什么呢？我们还不知道。还没决定呢。做点什么吧。某种实验性的过程。是的，我们需要
work that out. Thanks very much for listening. See you all soon. Something. Experimental process. Yeah, we need to work that out. Thanks very much for listening. See you all soon. Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
把这个敲定下来。非常感谢大家的聆听，我们很快再见。做点什么吧。某种实验性的过程。是的，我们需要把这个敲定下来。非常感谢大家的聆听，我们很快再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、享受无广告收听体验并加入我们的聊天社群，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。